hey guys this is andrew from
traincensus.com so for those who are
watching my video for the first time
i've been working as a professional
trader for the past six years in hong
kong
and right now i'm doing some youtube
videos where i show you guys how i use
technical analysis and how i read
the volumes i read the flows the option
interest every
financial data that i can have to
predict price action
so in today's video i want to show you
what i see on gamestop let's get into it
[Music]
so this is my different scenarios let's
focus on what is happening here guys
so basically if you remember if you
watched my previous videos i was telling
you that for now
the price action is so let's actually
start from here so this is the 29th of
march so this is basically the past
month on gamestop and you can see that
we are basically going
lower so i think we are still in the
correction that is here guys
that is doing something like this one
two somewhere i don't know where is the
second wave going and three four five
and actually three
four five and i think we're going to go
to 800
if the bullish case is actually the one
that is happening
um what i'm actually wondering
is where is the second wave going and to
answer that
i use idiot wave principle and i use
trend lines and try to see if this
second wave gives me any signal of
reversal
for now guys i don't have it the basic
one is you know trend lines so i connect
you know the recent highs that i have in
my last wave which is this one so here a
b c we're doing a c wave here let me
elaborate if you guys
you know we need to see it
and i don't know if this c wave is
complete or not i mean
if it's an abc here it's actually it
needs to go
lower it needs to go at least to the
bottom of wave a
so what is actually another scenario
that is happening i think
right now but to be the
the truth i need to have some volumes
picking up
we could be just in one two three four
five like this this is actually possible
as well
but once again here i'm i don't know if
the second wave is going here
or here you know i don't have that much
visibility
in the range between
here and the strand line because
if we go below 130 i know
that that basically this cannot be one
two
i know that you know something like this
is not possible
because if it's a one two it needs to
actually hold
above the beginning of wave one
and for now we are supported by the 200
period moving average
which is good news and
the question is are we going to break
this trend line on the upside and
actually make a third wave
which is definitely a very likely
scenario
or are we gonna just simply correct
deeper and make a new low
blue here if we do that for example this
moving average here it would help us a
lot i was telling you guys that here
you know in this area you need to check
the 20 period moving average because it
was hold
acting like a support very well in this
whole you know kind of beginning of
reversal we had
on the 15th of april and i told you that
if we break out
this we're gonna see some strong
downside movements and
here what is a breakout two consecutive
candles below
the support level you are checking so
one here
on the first time frame once again guys
four hours time frame if you don't know
where to go go to the four hours time
frame
so first candle closing below second
candle closing below so here guys you
know
that your breakout occurred so of course
it can be a fake breakout you can hope
for that
but the reality is that what happened
after the second candle is two more
candles and then
a strong move down so you could have
avoided this
you know ten percent move down and then
guys as usual where is the next support
either
you find some trend lines so here
here you could find one actually
let's see if this would have worked i'm
doing it with you guys right now you
connect this and this
okay you see it's going a bit lower so
this trendline wouldn't have
had to for example but this is the kind
of stuff you can do
and if you don't find any trend line
level
use the moving averages guys they are
very efficient and they're giving you
very precious signals and here if for
example
you want to stop your position here and
buy back here you can
oh just if you want to buy the deep you
don't want to sell any shares which i
can understand
then you simply wait for some signals to
reload so either you buy here
or the best thing for you guys to do
is to wait for the breakout on the
upside of this trendline
you know guys when i give you some
information like this
keep it in mind look here it would have
helped you and
many many times it would have helped you
this is what i would do if i was
training and stop at work for example i
would
keep long biased so some shares and i
would basically buy
any i don't like to buy when the price
is going down i like to buy
when the price is already shifting up
but at the very beginning i use very
early signals
and i'm buying reversals and here what i
would do
guys in this situation i would wait for
this trendline to be broken
and i don't buy the breakout i buy the
retest you see this is the kind of
trading i like to do
so each trader is different you know but
so it's something like this because once
we break this on the upside yes the
probability we go higher
is much much higher than you know
if we go here of course we might see
some rebound we might
see something like this right if the
price shifts lower
here we're gonna have to rebound but if
you buy it
you can buy it but then maybe put a stop
loss just here guys
just below because it's not impossible
we just break it little bit
and go lower as well you know so this is
you know something
you need to keep in mind is that if you
buy are you
going to keep your shares are are you
going to stop your position if you go
below
i know you guys going to keep your
shares so better
buying it when it's gonna go higher
right you don't want to buy it
and see the price action going lower i
know that
this might have happened to you guys if
you buy the dip
when the deep just arrives that's not
what you should do
if you want to buy the dip you know it's
very rare the price action goes down
and doesn't consolidate usually when you
have you see here for example
you have this consolidation each time
the price action is going lower
so even here you had one two three
three candles you have 12 hours to buy
it so if you buy
here for example guys you know you're
getting hammered
all right so don't buy when it's going
down wait for the consolidation wait for
the bullish signals to come and then you
enter your trade
and you can do this on every type of
time frame and here what is happening is
that gamestop is going lower guys all
right
so we don't know where it's gonna button
so you always can try to find where
where it's gonna button
but the truth is that nobody knows what
i know is when a reversal is likely to
happen
and this is the right time to enter your
trades
wait for the reversal so here i'm giving
you one
if we break this line and this is going
to be true
until you know early may this is going
to be
your bullish signals and here when i see
the 100 moving average coming here
it looks like it might want to break it
and once again it's in line with my
scenario that we're doing a one two
three four five so this is a very likely
scenario it's actually for now my
preferred scenario
and i would change my mind if we trade
below 130
then i would see an xyz probably going
to 110
maybe slightly below but not longer but
for now this is
the preferred scenario i would just like
to see more volumes guys you know this
is what is missing is true for amc as
well
there is you know the market is actually
out of steam
but i don't have any bearish divergence
on gamestop or amc and i have bullish
divergences on amc i don't have any
bullish divergences on gamestop i showed
you guys how to you know
see it you connect for example the slow
and the slow and you see if the macd is
going lower
but here the macd on this chart is
actually going slightly higher
so it's not a bullish divergence but
it's not bearish as well it's just no
information
one last thing i want to show you guys
is the open interest
so i'm an option trader guys and i like
to use the data that i have on the
option market
and on gamestop like i showed you guys
already it's insane what we see you know
i compute all the open interest for
every strike so this is the strike 100
200
300 and i can see guys the like
huge number of shares that i have on the
800 strike
if i you know check just the number of
shares it's here we have
11 almost 12 million equivalent short
shares beared by professionals in the
market against
retail so it's like 21 of the total
float share
once again those options they don't have
a delta is equal to one so the exposure
is lower
so i compute the exposure myself using
some formulas that i have here
and i come up with the real short
synthetic short interest that is in the
market right now
for now we're having 400 million us
dollar which is five percent
and it has this kind of shape all right
so it's like very huge on the 800
strike this is very bullish guys this is
some very bullish momentum
when i compare to amc for example amc
has a total of
a maximum of 12. and you can see that
for example for now we're having five
percent on amc
and the maximum would be 12. so this is
what we call the gamma if amc goes to
100 for example it becomes 12
and it's gonna be distributed like this
okay let's do the same stuff for
gamestop
if game stop so for now we have five
percent so it's
similar so five percent of synthetic
short interest on gamestop
but if gamestop goes to another two
thousand so i'm taking like
obviously some very crazy prices because
i want to make all this
delta equal to one then we're gonna have
the 21
that you find here because all the
options are deep in the money so the
exposure is equal to one
share one call option strike whatever
you want if it's below two thousand
by four which is deep in the money then
the exposure is hundred percent and you
can see guys that if this happens
the exp the synthetic would short would
be
mostly given by the 800 strike which is
insane because the hybrid strike
is very very far away from the price
we're having right now
and even the 690 guys is very huge so
this
is something that is completely
different from
what we usually have all right so let me
go back to 160
this is even 150 so even five percent of
synthetic short interest
is huge guys all right it's huge let me
show you just apple how it looks
apple guys looks like this so the
synthetic short is 0.6 percent
only i do the same thing i take all the
options until june
and you can see that it's concentrated
around the money and there is nothing on
the very upside and nothing on the very
downside
so this is very interesting to notice
and this is of course
a very very bullish sign guys okay when
you have this option market that
animated
this is very bullish and i also keep an
eye on the
volatility of those upside strikes and
it's still
around 190 percent if it's going to 150
i told you guys i will let you know this
is bearish because this means that
market makers don't need
that much protection for those kind of
strikes because they see that
it's fine so it's just one more
information because of course they can
be wrong
but for example right now market makers
are scared of the 800 level they are
very scared of it and that's why
they sell it for a very high price using
a volatility of
190 percent for apple the big strikes
are around 50
so it's nothing to compare and for amc
no this is not correct there are around
130 percent
i've seen that
it's not changing much about everything
i told you guys
it's making the synthetic shot slightly
lower because the quality is lower so
those options are diffusing
less whatever so the conclusion of this
is just that gamestop has a crazy option
profile
you know very very unusual very
explosive on the upside
that's going to create some crazy moves
in the market this is what we call the
gamma squeeze you know
is the synthetic short growing you know
when the price is going higher for
example only to 500
we go from 4 to 16 yes we're talking
about 4 billion us dollar that
professionals need to buy not to be left
short
so this is very bullish as well so yeah
to conclude guys
i'm neutral i'm neutral on gamestop of
course i'm bullish on the long run
especially when i check the option
profile but i'm neutral on the short
term
i'm waiting to see if we break this
right now it's the 155 level it's gonna
go down guys so every day it's slower
the breakout level is going to go lower
every day so buy it
when i mean i don't give financial
advice you know that
but if i need to buy it i wait for the
breakouts you know and
i buy the retest which is even lower
than the breakout
if we break out at 150 the retest might
be 145
something like this so keep this in mind
guys and if you enjoyed this video
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new
and stay close to show see you guys